[Musique]
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour l'ex-star
de télé réalité loana qui a été
transporté lundi dans l'après midi à
l'hôpital de hyères et serait entre la
vie et la mort après ses multiples des
pressions et tentatives de suicide loana
aurait sombré une nouvelle fois elle
était dans un état très grave et elle va
être transférée en hôpital psychiatrique
pourtant ce week-end en plein tournage
sur la côte d'azur elle s'affichait
heureux au bras de nicolas son meilleur
ami et d'une dénommée sylvie ortega
cette femme est aujourd'hui mise en
cause par plusieurs anciens lofteurs
pour l' influence néfaste qu'elle aurait
sur loana
mais quel est l'état de santé actuel de
loana selon-vous l'entourage de loana
est il dangereux mais réponse tout de
suite sur notre plateau à lui ça va me
soir bonsoir à tous alors on accueille
nos invités c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement attendu alors merci lire tes
gars d'être là vous êtes l'ami de wana
vous venez tout le temps avec elle vous
est tout le temps avec elle je vous ai
vu encore la dernière fois avec elle
lorsqu'elle est venue nous voir eryl
prayer à la parler de vous quand elle
était chez nous a dit que vraiment vous
êtes un voilà c'est plus proche et que
vous êtes toujours là pour l'aider merci
eric besson ex également à loana et puis
maintenant que vous êtes très amis c'est
une histoire d'amitié qui a dérapé un
moment mais on est surtout très très ému
et c'est sa petite soeur en fait et vous
êtes resté amiens voilà c'est dit c'est
ce qu'elle nous disait à la 1ère fois
elle nous disait vraiment qu'elle
pouvait compter sur vous tout le temps
alban bartoli mercier le bon d'être là
merci alors on vous connaît pas ce que
vous avez fait est chanteur avant que
oui bien entendu et vous avez enquêté
sur sylvie ortega alors enquêté c'est un
bien grand mot puisque sylvie ortega m'a
fourni les preuves de sa malveillance
sur un plateau d'argent donc casser un
peu ces impies démarre directement
d'ailleurs je tiens à te préciser je te
remercie pour toutes les phrases que tu
as fait aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
sociaux
tu as bien tu as bien vu tu as bien vu
que je n'ai absolument pas répondu
puisque je voulais y répondre alors
alors s'il vous plaît on va on va
revenir là dessus sylvie déjà comme en
valois n'a pas ce que vous avez eu des
nouvelles bien sûr j'ai appelé quatre
fois aujourd'hui
wipro vicié avec des heures les dates et
tous aujourd'hui j'ai eu quatre fois au
téléphone
loana ne connais absolument pas la
personne que j'ai en face de moi donc
égale banque étrillé un peu de charbon
je fais mon procès genre je ne savais
pas qu allemands étaient programm s'il
vous plaît pour les téléspectateurs
allemands qu'est ce que vous reprochez à
je réponds 30 secondes évidemment que
loana me connaît puisque j'ai partagé en
2017 le plateau des interviews sont en
stock people j'ai les preuves tout c'est
sur youtube on a partagé normes aimant
de soirée caritative ensemble donc
évidemment je ne suis peut-être pas
autant légitime que vous qui la
connaissait beaucoup plus puisque je ne
me prétends pas amie de loana
juste quelqu'un qui a croisé ma route
très régulièrement et a pour qui j'ai
énormément d'affection
il y a lorsque je reproche à silvio
dégâts tout simplement je j'anime une
émission qui s'appelle ils ont fait la
une
j'ai vu chez vous que loana était venu
jeu elle m'a beaucoup touché j'ai voulu
à recevoir sur mon émission évidemment
moi je n'avais rien contre toi au début
tu sais on sait déjà croisé à carrière
ici on a croisé 1 400 cas pas le doigt
le fait que tu reçois un petit peu
perché etc
moi je n'ai rien contre toi en revanche
en revanche quand j'ai adressé du coup
une note vocale tout à fait cordiale et
je n'ai pas dit bonjour ma sylvie j'ai
les notes vocales un an preuve je les ai
en capture quand je me suis adressé à
ses 10 pour la faire venir dans mon
émission
s'il y aurait gamma complètement choqué
avec ses notes vocales
alors en fait elle a clairement mis la
couverture sur elles dès le début en me
disant que loana bon était évidemment
faible en ce moment qu'elle prenait des
cachets et c'est donc évidemment je ne
peux pas aller contre ça mais en
revanche tu as tout de suite dit par
contre je suis extrêmement choquée que
vous m'ayez jamais invité dans votre
ennemi alors c'est toi si tu sais mais
c'est toi qui tu es
qui alors je te tiens de l'été dernier
sur ip de nouvelle à cette vie il évite
ces messages dans les allées j'avais
juste vous déjà des jeanneret
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux à ceux
qui vous accusent d'être une mauvaise
fréquentation pour loire soutient on ne
m'accuse pas l'être une mauvaise avec
son caniche ou du monde battu catane
accusé fréquentation je te dis c'est pas
les tumultes valeur sans cassure je t'en
prie faites accents quasi voilà alors
s'il ya déjà de une on me dis pas que je
suis mauvaise fréquentation me traite
carrément de criminels c'est vrai c'est
pas mais c'est vrai qu'ils vous plaît
s'il te plaît 2012
alors donc qui sont ces gens pour moi
qu'ils auront démontré de virtuel pour
ne traiter de criminels et de faire mon
procès alors justement guillon pourquoi
en côte hill vite criminelle pour les
téléspecteurs parce que certaines
personnes disent qu'elle aurait une
mauvaise influence sur le nam moi je
prends pas parti je voudrais juste dire
une chose c'est que quand on voit tous
les articles lohan entre la vie et la
mort et c'est un raccourci qui est très
facile à faire c'est trouver des
coupables en fait instantanément dire
bah c'est la faulx de sylvie c
faute de la télé c'est notre faute à
nous parce qu'on fait un documentaire je
voudrais juste dire que loana on
s'intéresse elle pas parce qu'elle va
mal parce que c'est les 20 ans du loft
c'est une date anniversaire bien sûr
donc nous on est là pour la traiter de
manière bienveillante ont fait un
documentaire sur elle comme on en a fait
sur jean pierre pernaut on a fait sur
plein de gens on la traite avec
bienveillance qu'on n'est pas là pour la
tirer vers le bas le principe du
documentaire c'est de l'emmener sur les
endroits qui ont marqué sa vie on était
dans le sud de la france avec elle donc
arrêté et j'ai franchement rien contre
vous je vous connais pas si bien que ça
je arrêter de vouloir trouver des
coupables instantanément la situation de
l'ona elle est très compliqué ça fait
dix années que c'est compliqué le loeuff
c'était à 20 ans donc voilà je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de trouver des
coupables et laisser les gens
tranquilles gilles verdez apprendra bien
sûr la personne à libre et de sylvie
avec tout mon respect pose problème et
dans l'entourage de l'om avait tout le
temps avec la décennie mais j'étudie
tout je suis tout le temps avec loana
pas sympa h24 évidemment je peux pas
être avec loana moi aussi j'ai une vie
non mais vous n'êtes plus proche mais je
suis la preuve alors quand on parle
justement de mauvaise entourage on
s'adresse qu'à moi puisqu'elle est
entouré de personne d'autre que moi
voilà alors j'y vois là parce que sylvie
on vous reproche d'avoir coupé
totalement lohan a du reste du monde il
faut bien le dire de l'utiliser pour
votre propre suis pas la notion est
également de la manipuler et vous êtes
chercher lui une personnalité
extrêmement sulfureuse vous avez
d'autres problem by lm il ya eu aucun
problème à et s'il ya eu des par exemple
dans la sphère du fils de sheila décédé
il ya une des plaintes quant à la
réalité alors je suis désolé qu'il
aurait déjà tué alors je suis désolé
déjà je déteste qu'on parle de ludovic
qui font se marie à la victime qui est
décédée qui est décédé et qu'il ne peut
plus se lever pour parler et dire ce
qu'il a à dire
donc vous parlez tous en son nom ok donc
tout le monde connaissait même avant mon
existence
les problèmes qu'avait ludovic avec sa
maman on est choqué de ce côté là on
rentre pas là-dedans d'accord ok son
mais qu'on me dise comme ça parce que
mon mari
est décédée dans mes bras que je suis
une meurtrière ont pas dit ça alors
qu'est ce que je fais ici
alors pourquoi les chiches pas en prison
benjamin castaldi moi je honnêtement je
me suis un peu renseigné sur vous c'est
vrai que vous n'êtes pas bonne
réputation va pas se mentir
pourquoi c'est quoi avec qui bah écoutez
globalement vous n'êtes pas bonne
réputation
quand vous entourer les gens
généralement il ya du malheur qui se
passe autour vous parlez de 2,2 d'olic
et de savoir que si je connais très bien
très très très très bien très touchés
par ces mêmes arènes de mont vie donc je
vous dis à quel point je la connais
quand on prononce votre nom jeu
franchement c'est pas un nom qu'elle a
envie d'entendre et et et le pape vous
enfoncer plus mais c'est vrai que vous
faites beaucoup du jeu trop beaucoup de
mal et de malheurs autour de vous les
mecs là qu'ils gardent beaucoup dont 10
dans lequel ne vit que c'est pas des
ondes il ya beaucoup de non dits jockey
ou vous dit les choses de moi ce qu'on
me disait vous avez écourtée et comme on
dit à marseille vous l'avait poussée du
côté où vous allez tomber le fournisseur
en faisant comme on la soupçonne deux
fois deux voies de la cam à loana vous
des gens moi je dis gentiment je veux
pas de procès je vous dis avait été
demandé ce qu'on dit de vous écrire des
choses était fait mais clairement je
vous dire clairement ce qu'on doit voir
dans les rôles de fournir la cam à des
personnalités notamment d'en fournir à
loana il se trouve que ludovic et j'ai
là et je connais bien la version puisque
on me l'a racontée est mort d'une
overdose
moi je vous dis je vous dis
vous n'avez pas une image vous n'aimez
pas une image excusez-moi de vous aurez
très bien mais j'ai pas de l'argent mais
moi je vais je pense que j'ai fait moins
de valeur autour de moi de vous parce
que moi du tout à quoi quand j'ai parlé
à loana de sylvie elle me dit avec eryl
c'est la seule personne qui autour
d'elle et qui bah oui aujourd'hui c'est
à dire qu'on n'est pas trop ami nicolas
erin et moi même de nous trois et en a
aucun qui consomment de la drogue et
loire alors ça vous fait rire ça fait
beaucoup
ça ne me fait pas rire si tu rigoles
c'est que quelque part
et voilà alors quand je veux montrer
léger j'aimerais avoir l'avis dérivés
léger si vous allez c'est différent j'ai
déjà moi quelqu'un qui me fait un procès
comme ça gratuitement faute à un profilé
général les gens de lettres les jeunes
salaire que je me dis tu sais quoi
la phrase qu'on ne sait pas quand on ne
sait plus quoi dire c'est de dire comme
ça elle veut briller
j'ai pas dit ça un calcul ni briller
tuque train de travailler dessus dès que
le mot brillé en fait non sans menacer
la télé réalité on est au liban et alors
je l'avais population est aujourd'hui
mais pour me mettre en lumière pour
vivre de mon métier ce que je fais
aujourd'hui s'appelle sylvie second
trimestre ils vénèrent sylviane
boursiers j'aimerais avoir l'avis des
ris est important et rilke et et l ohada
nous dit elle même est ici sur ce
plateau vous êtes son ami le plus proche
avec donc sylvie et et nicolas vous
qu'est ce qu'on pensait d'eux c'est ce
qu'ont pensé que sylvie parce que
aujourd'hui sylvie elle a été au centre
de toutes les polémiques on s'aimerait
ainsi dire dans nuit voilà qu'est ce que
vous pensez de l'amitié de sylvie et
loana scoop on sait que si vite une
personne des fastes pour pour loana
c'est difficile à dire moi j'ai eu
l'onac him on a dit du bien que mais
elle vous en avez du bien à vous aussi
je lis et j'entends ce qu'on dit aussi
autour d'elle bon ben ni oui ni non je
ne sais pas quoi penser moi parce que
c'est vrai que l'on se connaît pas c'est
incroyable à voir derrière vos amis mais
ce n'est ce pas je bats
je n'habite pas les mêmes vues en même
temps que loana est mon ami m'a manqué
de respect vraiment j'ai entendu parler
de toi qu'il ya que quelques mois avant
je te connaissais pas quoi loana ne m'a
jamais parlé de toi avant et le prends
pas mal je sais vous croisez dans des
soirées ça je sais mais tu n'étais pas
dans la vie de loana il ya encore
quelques mois et là tu es devenu très
proche de loana dans sa vie j'ai été
mais c'est à dire quand on est amis
depuis très longtemps mais on n'a pas du
tout trois centraux est ce que tu penses
que on va moi je moi je mais il faut
parler franchement aujourd'hui le gros
problème de loana je me perds mon rôle c
est la 10 6 et la nacam c'est la came
c'est la droite quand on nous a dit
qu'elle avait repris de la drogue
apparemment et c'est pour ça qu'elle est
retombé et l'aurait privé du gsb
d'accord donc péril vous lorsque vous
étiez avec et moi j'ai eu un texto de
loi n'a aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui vous a
dit manat si c'est ton ami nul ouanna
moi c'est ma petite soeur tu vois moi
c'est ma petite sur l'aude et on a eu
très peur pour le web très très peur
j'ai appelé c'est moi même qui ai appelé
le sait mal tourner sur l'eau on a vu
cela par les caves et dans les médias
qu'ils annonçaient qu'elle est entre la
vie et la mort moi ça fait deux jours
que je dors pas je comprends oui et la
loi nome a envoyé encore désolé pour
hier sylvie m'a donné un peu trop de
médicaments parce que j'étais stressé et
du coup j'ai mal supporté non ça là je
lui ai donné la veille à nax oui je sais
j'ai le même message axé attention alors
elle est très fragile on l'a calmé parce
que là mois à l'hôpital c'est moi qui
devais emmener je suis rentré avec sa
valise est en fait dans son sang c'est
bien du siège hbh dégâts mais qui donne
dans sarlat qui comme ça qui lui a donné
sa toute façon si tu me tues une quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas détecter à
l'aéroport doute qu'il eut d'autres
choses à spa sculpté elle peut le
commander sur internet est partout sur
internet où le discernement pour faire
ça en ce moment
je commande et soeurs je ne porterai pas
le chapeau tu n'auras pas mais le
charbon alors déjà je lis des choses
justes pour un recadrage
alors je ne fais pas ton procès voilà je
vais revenir à des jeux des manières
sans je tiens les meubles et tu sais
quoi je sais bien quelque chose c'est
tout vous êtes tous entrain de pleurer
loana mais qui va la voir qui va lui
apporter des mouchoirs et c'est très
bien alors je vais revenir justement je
suis avec mon temps j'ai prêché elle qui
va lui verser quoi c'est parce qu'elles
sont effectives même son ex que je
n'apprécie pas du tout pas que tu
répondes sur facebook en justes noces et
tous ces thèmes en deux secondes même
lui il y a et l'ue a apporté à manger
ok le cadre hockey quand même lui jeta
fait est-ce que je peux revenir sur ce
que j'ai de garder a dit pardon quand il
a dit que vous aviez une image un petit
peu plus tard hier un petit peu
racoleuse et c est assise et je suis aux
play out je vais presser rarement sûr
sûr sûr c'est story généralement tu te
mets en scène avec loana non à dix huit
mois à l'heure quand tu mets sûreté faut
y aller bien sûr j'ai retrouvé moi tu
fais pas une promo tuez moi je vais pas
annoncer tu vois contrairement à toi et
je te dirai si le meurtre tu as fait des
menaces demeurent ouvertes sur des
réseaux sociaux mais je veux van meer de
salaire experis it est une première
aussi équilibré que toi qui 2 qui doit
quitter l'eau sur la tête s'il vous
plaît je n'ai celui-ci de criminels je
suis désolé sylvie j'ai fait une faute
en 2014 avec loana ne puis vous ne vous
dites
amis depuis des années ce qui est
totalement faux et ce qui est vrai c'est
que vous êtes ré entrer dans le concret
dans la vie de l'onu pour savoir vous
être est entré dans la vie de loana il
ya quelques mois la surprise générale et
pour la maintenir sous votre influence
de nombreuses personnes dont moi je
reconnais pense que vous la manipuler
vous la maintenait sous influence au
moins au moins on lui doit les écouter
on lui donnait des choses est bondée au
téléphone avec moi aurait donné pour les
médicaments service était trop de
médicaments savez très bien
gilles qui était au téléphone avec moi
le jour où il y avait sonnex un ami
j'étais chez elle mois où la police est
débarqué moi et que vous m'avez passer
la pommade et blablabla non je n'ai pas
passé comme je vous ai parlé en gros
boulot vous oui moi et avez-vous des
pieds avec fait dans grave bien sûr
c'est mon boulot blacks ça monde et est
ce que vous fournissez pas trop de
médicaments l'alabama sienne je ne faut
ni aucun médicament alors non c'est un
médicament herring ça avec
l'autorisation des pompiers aux cantates
et inclut de tétanie en attendant les
pompiers ou un médecin
on lui donne un à nax sous la langue il
ya plein de gens qui supputent des
choses ici autour de cette table celui
qui a été le plus proche de l'ohada qui
l'a suivi pendant des jours et des jours
c'est vous guillaume genton alors visité
avec sylvie mais moi je pense que je
pense que la question de la drogue de
qui fournit quoi qui s'est beaucoup trop
tôt çi pour juger sans connaitre voilà
maintenant je pense qu'il ya deux choses
qui la font beaucoup souffrir
actuellement c'est évidemment ces primes
de droits mais c'est aussi la solitude
et je suis pas en train de prendre la
défense de sylvie je voudrais juste dire
que voilà n'ont fait ce documentaire on
est passé par sylvie parce que c'est son
ami et c'est son agent celle qui la
représente aujourd'hui est que sylvie ce
qu'on peut pas lui enlever
c'est qu'elle est présente elle et avec
elle le matin le soir elle va se coucher
avec elle elle s'occupe d'elle elle
essaye de lui gérer des contrats
voilà donc on peut pas lui enlever ça
maintenant porter des accusations
effectivement la qualifier l'a qualifié
d'assassin je trouve ça et je ne suis
pas en train de la défendre je pense que
j'arrive un peu violent et de dire comme
ça de n'importe où qu'elle fournit de la
drogue d'accord mais ce que vous avez
dit mais c'est que c'est clairement si
on lui reproche on lui reproche de lui
fournir de la cama loi n'a donc tous ces
gens là qui accuse et il ya beaucoup de
gens aussi moi j'ai vu beaucoup de gens
qui connaissaient le qui ont vu une fois
loana ya 15 ans etc qui domine mais ces
unions ils étaient où et pendant toutes
ces années où l'honnêteté et et était
dans la merde alors là vous traduis
quand même comme un grand guillaume
parce que justement j'ai une eau à na et
il ya de lofteurs la casa qui déboule 20
ans loana on t'aime loana
chalon a un truc loana voilà bon ok très
bien
la dernière fois que j'ai mis loana donc
en clinique
personne ne s'est manifesté personne
il ya eu personne mickels a mis stephen
blais là je sais pas qui ne sais pas si
c'est pareil c'est aussi un steven va
proposer de la même si villa est sur rtl
donc là ce raid et moi n'y a jamais
pardonné mois et vous souvenez pas
qu'après la mort de ludovic vous m'avez
envoyé un sms et l'opposant de 2,2 un
témoignage chargeant chela mais d'une
façon invraisemblable et je me suis dit
pas c'est que jeune femme ne me connaît
pas fallu nous propose d'augmenter tout
on n'est pas forcément dans ce cas qui a
vu luan a longuement enfin vous l'avez
eue décédé il ya quelques temps moi
qu'est ce que vous en pensez tout ça moi
je lui il ya quelques temps alors c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué on connaît pas
ces personnes après moi j'ai une
question pour allemand tu es tu es venu
sur le plateau
kouao contre s'il est véritablement mais
qu'est ce que tu as de concret contre
elle
alors j'ai des notes vocales qui montre
que a évidemment elle a essayé de tirer
la couverture gmail complètement
incohérent qui ne sont pas les propos de
c'est à dire qui tirait la couverture
elle alors elle m'a reproché à de
nombreuses reprises elle m'appelle les
30 secondes de loana et sur cinq minutes
de notes vocales elle me parle que du
fait qu'elle a envie de parler de lui de
méchants scène mais qu'apparemment avait
tout pardon mais je les ai vues sur des
questions non non tu mets tu me laisses
parler de me donner la parole à aller
chez le porc
voilà pour tirer la couverture sur elle
qu'elle était scandalisé qu'on l'avait
pas invitée et qu'apparemment l'éruption
salines intéresse plus personne et que
c'était le gentil monde de la télé mais
qu'elle m'aimait beaucoup effectivement
alors qu on s'est croisé deux fois à
calmer on soit grave autre chose
on ne peut pas donner du crédit à ce
genre d' entourage pour loana sachant
que aujourd'hui elle n'a fait alors
c'est juste personnel elle n'a fait que
me charger sur internet et elle en plus
diffuser mon numéro de téléphone sur son
cas comme un jeu merveilleux stationné
tout temps des mois on n'est pas là pour
parler de ça parce qu'il y va on va
parler de l'ohada est équilibré désolé
ril et riil jeu on le sent vous êtes
très ému par ce qui arriva à loana mais
aujourd'hui vous aimeriez quoi pour luan
alors loana elle a un ami dont elle est
très proche un garçon avec qui qu'on
avait rencontré au restaurant aller à
l'époque et qui était directeur du
restaurant
ce garçon s'appelle nicolas est ce que
nous a dit nicolas est vraiment un
garçon très très bien et moi ce que je
pense
le conseil que je vais donner à loana
c'est qu'elle quitte paris en plus
nicolas un super projet à lui proposer
il peut l'héberger peut s'occuper d'elle
je pense que il faut qu'elles qu'elles
aient rejoint de ce garçon ensuite cela
l'empêchera pas par exemple vous vous
lui avait tendu la main je lui ai parlé
et il m'a dit qu'elle serait super
heureuse pourra revenir chronique de
temps en temps il nous a une fois par
semaine voilà donc prendre l'avion le
train c'est rapide
on a envie de l'aider on en voit là elle
peut quand même venir de temps en temps
ici moi elle m'a demandé de relancer
love me tender le cd qu'on a enregistré
tous les deux pour essayer de faire des
spectacles éventuellement quand corona
sera passée enfin voila mais il est un
cadre on est et s'il sylvie qui est
aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya plein de gens
voilà qui sait trouver des coupables qui
sont tournés vers sylvie vous avez envie
qu'elle reste avec sylvie que sylvie
partent avec elle ou que elle elle la
laisse un peu tranquille
peut-être pour nous des distances
pendant quelques temps le temps que les
choses se calment et de façon lohan alto
rappellera si vous n'êtes vraiment pas
tu sais très bien
justement ils m'ont proposé mon père m a
même proposé de vivre et de faire une
colocation avec elle une évidence que
j'ai entendu que non bien évidemment
loana c'est quelqu'un que j'affectionne
énormément que j'aime beaucoup mais
hélas ce qui n'est pas fiable puisque on
ne peut pas être guéri en trois mois
comme ça surtout en ayant été en hôpital
juste un mois là on peut lui donner
raison c'est vrai que le problème des
personnes fait qu'actuellement des
addictions
imaginez vous êtes au régime vous mangez
plus demain vous passez devant une
pâtisserie tous les jours au bout d'un
moment vous avez craqué vous allez la
défoncer bon bah c'est le problème de de
lolo donc voilà il faut entre autres il
pas l'attenté quarry ses problèmes de
drogue vous qui avez été sept titres et
sont avec elle vous avez essayé de lui
parler là dessus est ce que et j'ai
l'impression que je vous avoue qu'elle
mangeait tout alors j'ai rencontré loana
en 2009 elle avait déjà ses problèmes
d'addiction voilà et c'est très très dur
quelqu'un que des adaptations 2009 en
2009 je les connais ya douze ans et je
me permets de ces crédits c'est très dur
de sera de faire décrocher quelqu'un a
une addiction sûr et je me souviens
loana un jour j'étais dans la voiture
mais on voit un message avec sa photo
elle me dit aujourd'hui je suis très
très mal je me sens vraiment pas bien ça
va déchirer le tort je suis allé à la
quête à la cathédrale notre dame
j'ai allumé un cierge et prier pour elle
et j'ai dit à dieu je suis et je lui ai
demandé j'ai dit à dieu j'ai rencontré
une femme elle est comme nous tous
elle a des bons côtés elle a des côtés
moins bon mais je suis persuadé d'une
chose c'est qu'elle a une bonne âme et
fait ce qu'il faut pour la sauver et moi
continuera à veiller sur elle
il faut agir et je continuerai à veiller
sur elle et après tout ce qui s'est
passé est là encore en vie elle est
sortie la paire aujourd'hui ou pas oui
elle va bien j'ai eu alors au téléphone
j'ai senti que ça allait bien moi ces
moments qui s'occupe de son chien à la
maison j'ai récupéré le chien donc ma
mère s'occupe du chien voilà et puis je
laime comme une petite soeur quoi je dis
on a vécu des choses tellement forts
ensemble
que ce sera mon ami jusqu'à la fin des
fois on s'engueule défoncement la tête
par exemple n'a pas elle n'avait pas
apprécié à l'époque ce que je lui avais
dit sur son ex
parce que moi j'avais compris qui était
ce garçon depuis longtemps depuis déjà
2013 j'avais essayé de prévenir les gens
disent on fait attention à ce garçon
fait attention à ce garçon enlevé la
photo là parce que plus vous montrer en
photo plus mais heureux lui donc fait
attention à ce garçon est ce que je
disais en 2013 vient d'arriver il ya
quelques temps la voilà des phillies est
elle souffre de solitude mais je pense
qu'il vaut mieux parfois être seul que
mal accompagné aujourd'hui loana elle a
besoin de personnes pur brillante et
lumineuse donc si vous pensez que c'est
vous c'est super et c'est tant mieux si
vous pensez que vous même vous avez des
petites failles et que ça peut être
compliqué pour elle pour si vous l'aimez
vraiment prenez un peu de distance et
lui une chance il faut il faut des gens
hyper semble tenir à et pure ou pas pour
moi je vais juste posé une question et
je la pose de manière totalement neutre
et impartial aujourd'hui loana on va pas
se mentir et elle gagne pas des mille et
des cents elle roule pas sur l'or
c'est plus la star que c'était ya 20 ans
quel serait l'intérêt de sylvie de vivre
sur son dos pour gagner de l'argent mais
la lumière non parce que c'est plus la
star canal dit la dernière fois ici
qu'elle avait plus d'argent bien sûr
mais la lumière n'est pas l'argent qui
nous intéresse c'est peut-être là on l'a
mis hors de lui
un problème quelque part c'est quoi je
sais quoi on déjà en appel même âge j'ai
deux enfants et donc fin de phrase alors
ce soir au mont vernon et puis tabouret
tous les castings ont ras-le-bol
je je je suis venu ici en vrai pas dans
l'intention de faire un procès puisque
mon message est très clair tu m'as
message alerte
moi je ne suis pas le meilleur amie de
loana je suis juste un petit média web
radio qui a voulu inviter loana que
j'affectionne puisque je vais croiser de
nombreuses fois sur ma route et que
c'est une fille qui qui m'émeut beaucoup
et j'ai cette réponse derrière la page
alors à la base je suis chanteur a la
base je suis chanteur évidemment ce
moment c'est un peu compliqué mais du
coup je fais d'animation mais je suis
chanteur donc j'ai été entouré par des
gens qui m'ont représentés si toutefois
il y avait quelqu'un qui me représenter
auprès des médias comme vous le faites
mais je serai scandalisée je serai
scandalisé parce que c'est pas le gêner
mais non merci
ses téléspectateurs ce sera pas s'il
vous plaît voilà oui à 91% et voilà les
d'unica toujours raid 1 9% alors je sais
pas s'ils s'adressent directement à
sylvie mais en tout cas ce que très vite
il ya quelque chose que j'aimerais c'est
que un jour et moi étant son ami
j'aimerais qu'un jour elle rencontre un
homme qui soit vraiment amoureux de
lettres et qu'elle voulait pas de loana
du loft
les grèves devraient être moi là et
jason là on n'ose pas tombé sur un mec
comme ça je bénis le senior et ben voilà
c'est ça le sera le mot de la fin mai